let's go to Grant from Iowa City Grant
welcome to the program
hey David
um
so I know you get a lot of criticism and
stuff obviously from people way on the
right side of you yeah and the left on
the Spectrum and well yeah the left two
that's just gonna say so for when you
get criticism from people left of you
um for me personally I like it just
gives me like a ton of anxiety I get
nervous about it because I I am afraid
of being like perceived as like this you
know negative whatever a Negative Nancy
we're not supposed to use Negative Nancy
anymore
I'm not sure yeah I don't know either
like even stuff like that I guess like
hearing that I would be like oh gosh
like you know I know please don't think
I'm a bad person
um you know I ate an egg please don't
kill me
um so I guess how do you kind of
personally um
handle uh you know getting criticism
from people left you who would say you
know you're either you're a horrible
person for what you believe or whatever
because for me just kind of naturally
wanted to live that pace of like
everybody it's just like yeah I don't
know it really bends me out of shape
well here's the thing a lot of this
stuff in person
would not become what it is when you're
leaving someone a voicemail or leaving a
comment on their videos people are just
by their nature much more
confrontational online and so I see you
know these people who attack me from the
left but we agree on like 95 of stuff I
don't get too bent out of shape about it
quite frankly I don't really pay much
attention to any of it I just kind of do
my thing and and try to focus on what
I'm doing and learn and read as much as
I can and modify My Views when I feel
that uh the facts point me in a in a New
Direction and I try to screen out as
much of the noise as possible left and
right
right right yeah I'm sure that's
absolutely necessary for you as well
like yeah you know having such a you
know a lot of uh encounters with so many
people
um I could not do what you do definitely
don't say that much absolutely
but uh yeah I know I was just wondering
and uh has it gotten easier for you like
as you get older too
um just like is it easier to screen out
the negative noise absolutely not take
things so seriously absolutely without a
doubt yeah no doubt about it I mean at
the beginning it was like one negative
comment which was by the way we only
would get one comment a day and it was
like a really big deal but yeah it
definitely becomes easier
yeah yeah
um no I'm just curious because it's like
I'm thinking like I'm way behind on this
stuff because
um I'm almost 26 now and I'm like I feel
like I get bent out of shape as if I'm a
seven-year-old or something yeah I mean
I think part of it is one of the things
is really understanding that for a lot
of these people that are so willing and
eager to criticize others
they probably don't feel that great
about themselves and often attacks on
others are more a reflection of the
attackers either low self-esteem or
trials or tribulations and once I
started thinking that like wow this
person must really have some horrible
stuff going on to be spending an hour on
the internet leaving me a hundred
negative comments I I kind of feel bad
for them more than anything else
yeah yeah that makes sense
um yeah sorry my question wasn't a
political one or whatever no that's okay
do you want a trivia question before you
go
oh gosh uh you can try I'm gonna totally
watch it because I'm quite nervous but
okay we can go for it I guess what what
is the typical name for a dried plum
when you buy it as a dried fruit what do
they call a dried plum
um a prune you're absolutely correct
all right my friend thank you for the
call I appreciate it yeah thanks David
all right take care uh there's Grant
from Iowa City really excellent
excellent execution there on the um on
the trivia trivia question that could
have gone bad it could have gone very
bad and thankfully it did not let's go
to Summer from Metro somewhere I can't
see it's met where are you calling from
Samir
so mayor left okay so mayor apparently
did not want to be on that's uh that's
interesting let's go to instead Garrett
from Chicago Garrett welcome to the
program
hello Mr David the Pac-Man sir
uh welcome thank you
um I my question is about
um
uh like the popularity of candidates uh
when affecting other people that are
running in the same election uh I worded
that poorly okay uh just to give you an
example uh in Georgia the uh Brian Kemp
is currently leading six or seven points
in most of the polls okay uh and he's a
republican obviously whereas uh Warnock
is currently up anywhere from three to
five
um what I saw is Warnock is up 1.3
1.3 okay well
um I'm I'm just I have 538 pulled up the
most recent polls but yeah
um so uh
my question is will the will the
popularity of Warnock or the on of
Warnock or Kemp affect the uh do you
think it'll affect the turnout of the
other side like do you think Kemp's
popularity will improve uh Walker's
chances or do you think warnock's chant
or warnock's popularity will improve
Stacey Abrams chances oh I that is so
specific I have no idea listen turn out
in midterms predicting turnout in
midterms is very fraught and difficult
and every election cycle is oh turnout's
gonna win it for this person or that
person and it's so difficult to predict
and your question is even more specific
which is whatever base level of turnout
is to be expected will one candidate's
popularity buoy or sync another can I
just have no idea I think all we can do
right now we're a month out it's
basically four and a half weeks or
something until the the election roughly
is
make sure you're registered make sure
you know where to vote and make sure to
vote that's it and I think all of these
calculations they're interesting
questions we're going to know in
retrospect only once we get exit poll
data I don't know we we've just really
got to make sure not to lose any of
these winnable races
okay uh thank you very much Mr David the
Pac-Man sir do you want a trivia
question before you go of course what's
the most expensive spice by weight and
when we say spice we're talking about
cooking what's the most expensive spice
by weight
so not the spice from Dune no no no no
um
oh geez probably
uh
um I'm gonna say I can only name like
three spices I'm gonna say time no no
time is cheap oh my God it's almost a
weed it's almost invasive the answer is
saffron it's saffron
oh yes of course yeah yeah all right
very good thank you for the call
thank you sir all right I really
appreciate everybody who called in and
spoke to me I even appreciate people who
called in and didn't speak to me the
people who didn't call in I'm not so big
on you folks but uh no in all
seriousness we will take calls again
we're gonna take a quick break and we
will be back with more show right after
this